the Joe Rogan experience you know my
favorite story about people being a good
guy moe I mentioned Moe found earlier
he's been on the show so I feel like I
can mention him
um assuming that your listeners like
have this like amazing capacity for
attention do but so Moe Fallon show and
mo Fallon talks about dude this is like
a third this is like a fifth hand story
but Moe fans body meets the guy that
used to be like who's the dude in the
Nerds movie who like nerds
oh yeah oh girl yeah okay check this out
wow I'm so efforts Moe's buddy meets the
dude who was older in the nerds and
nerds not the nerds nerd scifi old man
so and the guy that doesn't want to
bring it up but he can't help himself
bring it up he's like you know I loved
you and nerds so the guy goes into this
big thing like he's like do you have any
idea what it would be like to have like
your whole life defined by some role you
did long ago and I'm a thespian and I do
theater now and you people to bring this
up all the time Oh nerds you know and he
does it like he like is cool with right
right and rolls into it and the dudes
relief the he enabled him to like have
that recollection mmm you know he was
always like yeah okay people gonna look
and when I hear that now if I see that
guy I'm like that guy must be a cool guy
right cuz he doesn't take himself too
seriously
yeah because you could roll with it yeah
there he is nerds what's D do pro
wrestling or something branch of the
Nerds policy moving yeah yeah it mean
looks like a guy that you would cast in
a row or a role where he'd be mean to
nerds yeah some people take themselves
[ __ ] super seriously like that's one
of the best things about my careers like
I will for always be forever always be
the fear factor guy like if I don't
think that's true
ah that's definitely true with some
folks really yeah you watch
it's on TV I mean it's not understand if
I don't know that I don't know that
that's really the case with you I feel
like that you might have a wrong
impression of your legacy nah it's in
there it's definitely in there in there
but it's not it well maybe it's not
there but if anybody wanted like poke
fun at me that's always there and I
would welcome it like something's right
I don't think that prevent me from
taking my selves myself and my you know
I want to pretend I'm some sort of moody
artist that has always followed the path
of creativity and artistic expression
no all right hoard myself out for like
six years I think it's in your head but
I'm think it's in people's head maybe
yeah I don't know it's in some people's
heads I can remember the first place
that here you know what you know it
helps substantiate what you're telling
me I know where I was sitting the first
time I ever heard your name I know who I
was talking to and unfortunately I don't
like to admit this this is a long time
ago
unfortunately the point of contact when
I was like oh you're right
fear factor yeah yeah I mean [ __ ]
millions of people saw that goddamn
thing I need to tell you - that was the
first conversation when I ever heard the
word podcast really I know where I was
sitting I was talking to Helen Cho who
you know oh yeah I heard the word Joe
Rogan and the word podcast and had no
idea what either those things were
that's before you came on - yeah I'm
talking long time 2012 people did yeah
yeah I'm not like I'm not I mean I have
I don't want to say I'm a finger on the
pulse I'm not like a Luddite well that
was when I heard the word the podcast
was only three years old back then when
you first came on now it's ten years old
that graze longer growing that it was
2012 okay cuz that's when we went
hunting maybe 2011 I went hunting in
2012 yeah yeah
so it was probably two years old the
podcast was two years old and she said
if you're fact I'm like oh
[Laughter]